selon vous le processus de décision en
europe est il trop opaques
oui ceux qui sont pour le oui lève la
main à l'instant s'il vous plaît
comprendre les enjeux de l'union
européenne souvent source de
questionnement tel est le but de la
réunion organisée à montigny le
bretonneux par l'antenne de saint
quentin en yvelines du mouvement
européen
ça consiste à reprendre l'ensemble des
items qui sont diffusées dans les médias
qui pour la plupart sont relativement
négatif et qui donc vont les reprendra
par un enfant en fonction des questions
de la salle et les démonter avec des
arguments objectifs à l'appui parmi les
sujets abordés l'économie l'agriculture
ou encore l'immigration les décodeurs de
l'europe du soir sont des membres du
mouvement des jeunes européens et un
représentant de la commission européenne
en france le système qui a été créée
pour gérer les migrations l'a été à une
époque où la migration n'avait pas une
ampleur telle que celle qu'on a connue
en 2015 c'est la raison pour laquelle à
l'union européenne aujourd'hui est en
train de préparer une révision de ce
qu'on appelle le règlement dublin c'est
celui qui organise un petit peu tout ça
une quarantaine de participants sont
venus assister à cette réunion
la plupart des européens convaincus au
finalement parlant je voyage énormément
donc pour moi les frontières ouvertes ou
des pays sans frontières évidemment
c'est extrêmement important
c'est juste naturel et s'engager pour
l'europe parce que pour moi moi l'europe
c'est en garantie de la paix armée
européenne harmonisation fiscale et
sociale ou fonctionnement des
institutions
plusieurs guides à éclaircir en vue des
élections européennes du 26 mai 2019